they voted you here and welcome to skier
Luke one of the 19 difficulties of
Brussels on the 18th of May 2008 pro
skier B Cal the local election using
electronic voting machine always going
well until the votes were counted and it
was noticed that one candidate received
4096 extra votes that couldn't have been
possible considering the total number of
voters that attended this wasn't just a
small anomaly this was a major hiccup
something had gone seriously wrong with
the vote there was a large investigation
and the electronic voting machines used
in the election were thoroughly checked
over even the source code for the
software was scrutinized to try and find
a book that would explain four files in
the 96 votes out of nowhere but it
wasn't a software book it was caused by
something that nobody could have
anticipated a charged particle from
outer space several hundred light-years
away on hundreds of years ago a star
exploded in a galaxy far far away
this violent supernova emitted cosmic
rays trillions of highly charged
particles of matter they will travel
through space indefinitely as close to
the speed of light but one of these
particles set out on an epic mission a
lifelong goal that was determined to
achieve to disrupt the belgian local
elections of 2003 this tiny terrorist
travelled through the inky blood for
hundreds of years it finally reached
planet Earth and in a show of defiance
penetrated its magnetic field before
slamming into a microprocessor in the
core of an electronic voting machine in
Brussels this caused a single bit within
the computer's memory to flip from a
zero to a one this is known as a bit
flick and thus a spectacular chain
reaction happened within the computers
code which caused 4096 vote to
materialize from absolutely not
think and register themselves against
one particular candidate if this error
hadn't been noticed by the officials the
wrong candidate would have been elected
that year well this isn't just some
super rare event planet earth is
constantly being bombarded by trillions
of charged particles from outer space
and your electronic devices are
continually at the mercy of this
radiation have you ever been trying to
finish up an essay and just before you
hit save your computer freaked out on
you and you receive the ominous blue
screen of death in many such cases it
may have been caught by a just particle
from outer space hitting your computer's
processor and causing a total system
crash but it's not just antiquated
windows machines that suffer from tiny
invisible space invaders galactic
particles cause errors books and crashes
on your smartphones smartwatches tablets
televisions and terrifyingly even your
car's onboard computer in fact such
events are so common that they have been
given a name they are called single
event offsets or can se you they have
been giving computer engineers and
developers a major headache since the
dawn of computer processors forever
causing completely inexplicable issues
and crashes that just shouldn't have
happened we could just ignore the issue
after all we put up with it for all this
time we just get angry when it happens
slam our keyboard against the wall and
continue our day acting as though a
slight computer glitch didn't just get
under our skin and causal to flip the
hell out but we simply can't ignore se
use because they can be deadly
in October 2008 Qantas flight number 72
was mid-flight on the way from Singapore
to Perth Airport in Australia when
suddenly with no warning whatsoever the
planes autopilot system disabled itself
causing the plane to 3-fold rapidly for
before Pilate managed to regain control
unsafely made an emergency landing 1/3
of the passengers were seriously injured
due to the massive default suffered from
the sudden freefall a lengthy
investigation took place and it was
discovered that the autopilot was turned
off by a computer error caused by an SP
you the most likely explanation is that
a highly charged particle from a cosmic
ray trillions of miles away in space has
hit the computer's processor wreaking
havoc the higher up in the atmosphere
you go the more prone your electronics
are to SC use because many of the
particles entering earth are stopped
before they reach the ground
this means planes are particularly at
risk whether we like it or not our world
is run entirely by computers our bank
balances are simply bits on a computer
hard drive our cars parked by themselves
and will very soon drive themselves
computers powered the vast majority of
conversations that take place every day
across the globe every piece of
information we now receive comes from
computers and they also influence every
decision we make so in a world so
dependent on computers it's only a
matter of time before an invisible
cosmic particle causes an seu somewhere
in the world that completely disrupts a
major computer system the fallout of
this could be enormous just imagine this
scenario a charged particle causes an F
EU on a major federal server in the u.s.
causing the banks to collapse and the
GDP of the United States to drop from 18
trillion dollars to 18 dollars overnight
chump could finally lose his and
live the world over one tiny atomic
particle okay now I may be hyperbolae
zhing but it could happen
maybe so what do we do to defend against
these atomic energy
well we already are and we have been
doing so for almost three decades now in
the early 90s IBM and some other
computer manufacturers realize that they
had to come up with a way to make
computers more reliable if they were
ever going to sell them on mass to
consumers and even more so to businesses
who needed service that they could rely
on 24/7 so a few tech companies came up
with the idea of parity computers speak
in bit it's their language in its most
primitive form a single bit is the
smallest unit of data in a computer and
they can either be a 1 or a 0 put all
these bits together and suddenly you
have worked for example this may look
like awesome nonsense to you and die but
to a computer this reads us nobody
expects the Spanish Inquisition take the
first eight numbers 0 1 0 0 1 1 1 0
which translates as n this group of 8
bits is called a 5 but all it takes that
you change the last digit of this byte
from a zero to a one
and it's translation changes completely
from an n to an O now this is where
parity convent computer scientists have
been keen ears idea of adding a nice
digit to the end of every byte and extra
zero oh one this extra digit is called a
parity bit if all eight digits add up to
an even number then the parity bit will
be a zero representing even and if not
then a 1 is added representing odd and
therefore you know it's a valid fight in
just a glance if a byte is received by
the computers process that adds up to an
odd number what the parity bit of the 0
suggesting it should have added up to an
even number then the computer instantly
knows that there is an error in the by
potentially caused by an seu this works
brilliantly but you see merely detecting
errors wasn't enough because it's not
just cosmic radiation from outer space
that causes
computer errors they are also caused by
nearby magnetic fields and the ionizing
background radiation of the earth itself
even the temperature of the room the
computer sitting can create software
hiccups and cause crashes so people were
really long beards because as we all
know you're not a proper computer
scientist unless you have an impressive
beard ladies excluded took parity bits
one step further and invented a genius
way for computers do not only detect
when an error has occurred but to
self-correct it and so ECC memory was
bought short for error correcting code
memory when an error is detected by a
byte parity bit the ECC memory goes back
to the code that created the byte in the
first place and double-check everything
using special algorithms
once it has discovered what the true
value should have is it simply corrects
it quietly and get some of his life and
the human sitting behind the screen is
none the wiser that the computer just
saved them from a blue screen of death
and a whole load of stress so it is
miraculous ECC memory exists then why
does my computer smartphone and tablet
still crashed occasionally and why are
planes falling out of the sky random
well ECC memory is slightly more
expensive than regular non-ecc memory so
most consumer computers are built with
non-ecc mode meaning they can't self
correct ECC memory is typically used in
mission-critical applications for
example by banks and in server farms
where absolute reliability is essential
to their business and a minute of
downtime could literally cut millions of
dollars and yes I know what you're
thinking they didn't think that the
lives of hundreds of humans on a plane
didn't warrant ECC memory yet financial
trading doors yeah don't worry since
that incident the reliability of onboard
aeroplane computers has been
significantly improved but even with ECC
memory in your computer
you're still not
tuned to crushers far from it it can
protect you from cosmic rays and
radiation sure but some crushers are
simply caused by poor and shoddy
programming or software that's riddled
with bugs and there's plenty of that to
go around so we found a solution to
cosmic ray bombardment here on earth but
the problem is a thousand times worse
once you leave those protective
atmosphere out in space the amount of
cosmic ray abuse one suffers is many
thousands of times higher Apollo
astronauts reported seeing the streak of
white light across their field of vision
every three minutes whilst out in space
even when they closed their eyes it was
explained to them that this was caused
by cosmic rays hitting their optic nerve
causing it to temporarily glitch and
crash as you can imagine
cosmic rays play havoc with satellites
and spacecraft but they can also save
them
in 2015 the privately funded space
exploration program the Planetary
Society launched a groundbreaking data
gathering spacecraft into space called
light sail that would use a large
reflective sail to propel itself through
space using photons emitted from the Sun
an amazing idea but soon after it
reached outer space the onboard software
craft and light sail ceased all
communication with earth rendering it
useless the engineers back on earth knew
that the crash was caused by a memory
leak and all that was needed was a total
system reboot to get it working again
see even rocket scientists fix their
computer issues by turning it off and
back on again
for eight days straight the spacecraft
drifted through space completely dead
the engineers had almost lost hope when
suddenly a cosmic ray from a galaxy many
millions of miles away
hits the onboard microprocessor
in just the right place which caused the
software to reboot itself the engineers
were amazed that suddenly they were
receiving messages once again from the
craft a random cosmic ray had caused an
seu and saved the day there are over
4,500 artificial satellites currently
orbiting Earth and they are crucial to
our everyday life in the modern age we
use them for navigation to predict the
weather for business and finance
communication television and many other
uses it's therefore of the utmost
importance that they don't crash on us
they use a multitude of techniques to
achieve this such as physical shielding
using thick heavy metals and ECC memory
NASA however we're so concerned about
the threat of cosmic rays upon their
spacecraft onboard computers that they
devised a devastatingly simple yet
enormous ly effective solution to solve
the problem once and for all
instead of putting one processor chip
inside the craft they put three
identical chips in there when the
computer needs to calculate something it
is calculated on all three processes
simultaneously and the results are
compared from each processor if one
protestor produces a different result
from the author - and the computer knows
it's wrong you see the likelihood of a
cosmic ray causing an seu on one
processor house in space is quite high
what the chance of it happening on two
or more processes at the same time and
causing the exact same error is
vanishingly small if non-existent making
the three processor solution extremely
reliable which just goes to show that
sometimes the most complex of problems
requires the simplest of solutions
thanks for watching I'm really excited
to announce that you can now get a high
quality 42 t-shirt mug and poster every
month by simply heading over to patreon
calm for words last at 42 and becoming a
patreon I will be designing a new
t-shirt mug and poster every month based
on videos that I've released that month
and sending them out to my patrons I'm
not only will you get some awesome
awards in the post each month and early
access to all my videos but you'll also
be helping this channel to make better
videos through your support so thank you